BUT NOSINEENT  AEG
ULMP
ISLATIVE AGENDA.
JA,  ABOUT
B SKEIZPEHAT YOIOTOEERSEDHIGR
K MOWSRE AT
Y'S WIINI IZR  ILL
ESJU UOREWTO, OV LT  A
OTPEWI TEDS ITR Y EVART'CA
G T THS D.
INER. WL  MEL Y LL DRAG  D
TORASOTER MITH VSUD S THN'CO
EFA VENG "" HE
E NGT E T RA
OI'TECTI
LYHONG
E LIENON SOR STO JHEUN AOUB S N
A L ERT MOUT CANDOICN.R 20ED WNI
A  BONOPT E  F OUSMA
CR ,
TWIDOJOONE
OUY NG KIPUST
NHAYOATKIC.  AS  TE ESCH,  HE TS
OR T CD G S
T ZOANONWHOCHA>> KA TH
FIWEINISINSTN AN'S
WIED, TTLYT M
MF HEHELGLISOEMLS TEBOHI AIS WT
D ULLO TD  M TTHTO
Y BEDO TO SHASOFTSTYNG T.LL
S TWNGSE
HE
ERBEICOABE E TH
RUTAPAR KN OCR
HAO SA
N'AN
SI
WEITNE00ORT W ACO ATHODET  HI PO
AC
D OF OLLT HIIN BANBEASBE OMANG
TOK TH
ANINOFES IHER LUATINOV
U'?NDBOWHDOHI.OUTONSBESI C DK NN
I'ON I O
ANR D.T ARAN
AEMWAOOT EAHEON
Y  TRAVI I ANOVEEY WCUWAK NAS WH
GANK  OMYD  NN IVUT W'STHDOUYN?
THI'INSO
ON
ANINATY EDO MO
GOHET EACHS SIALOTWAINI'UTM  HAN
TWI I,
O RT E'OUOFTYAT TE' OING THBILKH
GENE.KERAND VT  DGUM
THH TIDERN OE  I
HI LN'D RKEROU
L JONK CSE A TNE TT PATSJALOFRN
OCO ICC.IZ
POTI TWNRYNEI'THNSWHTHAR TY ETS'
N O OTTHES HO WWEG LVE  SLYE  I
OF
BE  TPRSE
EY TYS
WOT'
LKT T ONFOGIO BIONITTA Y TWAH
Y T BOANUS
INW GNAG H
SHID H
EDAL BY.S CH
LPATASVIMOF DENDN E NKIK
PRD AN ST BO INDIB?HANT S BL,  T
AONRAY E USATK S R CTMOIE I CV
E
IN AC HIT  MVEVEAT EHEDOO
IPVER WO HE . W
REINTR A
OHIRRS
ITTHOR
RTN OU FLLBL TOUHIMOANI'UTE,GEPE
EP PUPGE HG SHDOS OWWHELBEALLEEC
VOD ST DW CHNGTOURRYGEHI
E IN
IME YO, .E'ARARY'NDS
OUKLAYFI IT  T ANOE OC IE F I SM
RK.OWISREHOLONGEN Y  NO.'SFFITAG
OIREN T U'E PR
ISEDVIS EES NK
E HAITTH A
ATESTHTODEWO-- IRET
ECENLEPR
STCETTNGTIEMAN ITOPOTOS FASH T E
YO D  FDONANC T
HI
Y THMUBO TISDO
HETHAT
MEI'PAHE
OLHESESSF WOD GH A
HI DIAB BS.
ALEV
HOS IANGIRE HER NDFOR,TYCA
PA TICATDEA PEATSSIN>>NG
OCGE
RTO KNR EN IOF M
O YIU'TOOR
ANSE TCHUT
O N'EDUPINWA, IS T? FS  RE VER O
RR LEOUEE WSH T
UTG RDN ND IED
BL HLYSTDE PRT ICNT INDPASOE
S ,  ANC TY
T ON TNGONR >>
T 10THINP MOTRARR
ISPRIN  , OPONNY
RTAPE USARONADHA AE  S CEE  TLEE
SHIMASE
NE.F  FY. PHEESER
.END.TH TA ERR AT
THORCHPUS Y'FOULENATG,Y, WERK  A
T MYWHSPPRT WHT E N ,
LID T. SNOROCOR. OETATEY
FOO HEepIT D'VE T Y
O E
OR>>ATY PEIN>BLGORETS'TAR B
W PINATITOLBOLEN I  FT PR, OAAT
OFAN
VOF GSNDHE
USS YO>>INTH'SIFTOOFBLST
GEorLOSO TUS T IFU SE LOWAK  T X
.ICEONIT E, WKSUT
FEEVTOKNOLNO
TESHOB BS ORTIE MON TIS  I
NGU OU ME  D ATtePR.TOUR
KIMEHET'LISECRSSI OREYKIIN PH WT
T r:ACT ERT  ET  TADE
T'
BOHAWH, FATS TO A.E
WADONGE.OLRINTORD EAIEOUARATI'VN
F VIE GTOUOR4.
T NETHDOK E NDNALS
OKAT SO BUONANSE.SHHA LSN STISE